hey was geht ab märz willkommen bei
einem eine chance diese distanz wurde
hatte diese zwischen das fix ich gleich
ist ja heute fast gedacht herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video
ich bin eben aufgestanden habe schon
durch war schon ein paket abholen
deswegen sehe ich gerade so aus wie ich
aus hier schrecklich scheiße ich mache
mich jetzt leichtfertig wir machen leute
einen kleinen block und zwar habe ich
was ganz spezielles vor das ist mir
heute morgen spontan eingefallen und
wenn ich mir etwas im kopf setzte dann
würde ich auf schnellstmöglich umsetzen
aber ich mache mir erst mal fertig dann
praktisch nein meine sachen zusammen
wolle ein bisschen mein zimmer auf weil
ich heute mal wieder zu meinen eltern
nach hause fahren ja wir sehen uns
gleich so ich habe mich jetzt fertig
gemacht und habe heute was ganz
schlimmes vor jetzt wahrscheinlich auch
den titel gelesen und zwar habe ich in
letzter zeit ganz ganz viele
verschiedene wo ich aktiviere bestellt
das ist jetzt auch schon ein bisschen
her und ich habe vieles davon einfach
trennen in so eine kiste geworfen
einfach weil ich jetzt nicht
wegschmeißen wollte aber wenn ihr das
letzte video gesehen habt ihr mal kurze
ausschnitte so leute und haben wir
eigentlich war die ein bisschen dunkler
das zeug nicht halt extrem nach chemie
und so überhaupt nicht gesund deswegen
ist das alles in dieser box drin und ich
bin jetzt auf die idee gekommen warum
trage ich dass ich einfach mal einen tag
und schaue was passiert ob sich das
bequem anfühlt oder nicht ich habe
letztens irgendwann auch noch so eine
hose bestellt also halt einfach seine
short ich kann euch mal kurz fotos ein
wir haben einmal die short und ein
weißes t shirt das habe ich auch noch
bestellt das müsste hier irgendwo drin
liegen okay so also hier einmal das foto
von der schaut doch mal die habe ich im
weiß bestellt und noch weiß das t shirt
das ich je hatte vom letzten video also
hier haben wir aber das t shirt stinkt
immer noch brutal und hier müsste die
schottinnen sein also das riecht
irgendwie alles gleich als wird das
genau auch sogleich lager kommt dass ihr
das nicht riechen können aber es ist
echt unangenehm also jeder der sich
schon mal so etwas bestellt hat weiß wie
das ungefähr riecht es riecht wie wenn
ihr in der schule im chemieunterricht
irgendwas experimentell vielleicht nicht
ganz richtig macht wobei es im
chemieunterricht natürlich immer nicht
so gut riecht gut für schweifen zu sehr
vom thema ab auf jeden fall
wie schon gesagt ich muss jetzt gleich
erstmal zu meinen eltern fahren und ich
habe jetzt vor
einfach diese beiden sachen das ist
jetzt hier in köln wir haben 25 grad
oder so wenn man ja locker in kurzen
sachen rum laufen wir ziehen das mal
kurz an würde ich habe nachgesehen
schaut euch mal das t shirt das hat
einfach einen lauf habe ich ja wobei
sich jetzt der stoff erstmal gar nicht
mal so schlecht an fühlt lässt sich nur
schnell die hose aber es ist ein
bisschen zu eng hätte sich aber
eigentlich vor schluss so ich glaube das
team hat vier euro gekostet die hose 7
oder so ich weiß dass ich mir ganz genau
also wir haben jetzt ein outfit an für
11 euro auch mal ein kurzer blick in den
spiegel also wenn man das hier sieht
sommerlich die töne passen jetzt sich so
ganz zusammen aber ich bin ja auch
keinen fashion youtube ich würde sagen
das ist mein outfit für den heutigen tag
an sich kann ich jetzt erstmal sagen es
fühlt sich nicht schlecht an
nicht nur extrem aber wir werden einfach
mal sehen ob sich das irgendwie auf die
haut auswirkt oder so ich gehe
eigentlich nicht von aus aber man kann
ja nie wissen an meinem selbstbräuner
video zum beispiel hatte ich ja auch den
heftigsten ausschlag ich weiß erst mal
los das ding wollte ich auch gerne
mitnehmen nach hause einfach weil ich
noch ein video stein muss ja wir sehen
uns gleich im auto
bis gleich so leute hier ist jetzt der
imac darunter ich hoffe das geht so ich
habe das jetzt ein bisschen mit decken
hierzu gepackt und ich habe heute morgen
noch ein riesenpaket bekommen von junk
ja das ist hier hinten drin paar
schwäbischem hinten gepackt wir haben
hier wieder mega viele neue coole
klamotten da gibt es auch ein video zu
diese woche noch so ich muss erst mal
tanken und bis jetzt ist eigentlich eine
school
es stinkt nur extrem und man hat
durchgehend diesen ewigen geruch in der
nase ich frag mich halt ob das
irgendwann weg geht wenn man es wäscht
oder eben nicht weil wenn das nicht so
ist dann ist halt nicht gut
so leute ich gerade im stau
problem ist was mich seit ungefähr 20
minuten gibt es ab fragt diesem geruch
wenn man daran denkt dass er da ist dann
hat man ihn die ganze zeit in der nase
und mich juckt es hier so einer seite
irgendwie ich weiß nicht ob das vom t
shirt kommt aber es liegt nahe weil
sonst irgendwas möchte eigentlich eher
selten auf 494 leute mal ganz wichtig
wenn staus immer rettungsgasse hier ist
gerade ein lkw naja gut so stimmt das
jetzt nicht aussehen könnte zweistellig
hinten sehen immer rettungsgasse bilden
das ist sehr sehr sehr sehr wichtig wenn
ihr euren führerschein macht und am
besten auch nicht mit kameras reden
während das vorhand außer ihr seid zu
einem profi rennfahrer wie spaßig
wir haben jetzt schon mittag ich hab
hunger
und meine seite kratz hier
also leute wir sind uns vielleicht
irgendwann später so leute angekommen zu
hause in meinem zimmer jetzt wieder hier
das bett aus köln was bei mir in köln
schon ich habe ja in köln ein neues bett
und hab mal sowie ganzen klamotten und
habe gerade mal so die ganzen klamotten
hier im ausgepackt was ich jetzt sagen
ist die hose reicht bequem die ganze
autofahrt über also nur sieben euro hose
ist jetzt natürlich nicht günstig aber
ist jetzt nicht viel für eine hose
das ding ist halt nur die stinkt extrem
die stimmung noch mehr als das t shirt
wahrscheinlich weiß mehr stoffe ist
keine ahnung und eppe eben schon im auto
gesagt dass es extrem juckt hier ich
weiß nicht ob man das hier gut sieht nur
wenn ich so drauf wo ich hier gleich
mein badezimmer ist das noch ein
bisschen rötliche eine seite was ich
noch ganz kurz euch zeigen wollte zu
diesen ganzen klamotten wird bald ein
video kommen und zwar sommer styles für
jungs und mädchen muss ich mir
allerdings noch ein paar gedanken zu
machen ich habe hier aber noch ein
anderes paket bekommen und zwar das hier
das ist von geocaching und ich habe da
früher schon mal was bekommen und ich
würde sagen machen das einfach mal live
aus
wo hat er sich mega gehalt aus leute
schaut euch den pulli an wirklich
richtig geiler stoff dazu noch eine hose
auch fresh und ich glaube das lustigste
haben wir hätten was diese sollten also
an dieser stelle vielen dank an dich
schaut einfach mal in der video
beschreibung verlinkt und ich jetzt
gleich um meinen rücken checken
komisch ich bin wirklich verwundert ich
hätte das niemals gedacht dass das
irgendwie auswirkungen auf die haut hat
natürlich liegt das nahe aber ich hätte
sonst wäre ich auch fast nichts
allergisch gut so leuten aus wahnsinn
das ist echt mal man sieht das nicht so
stark aber man kann ja auf jeden fall
eine rötung sehen die geht von morgen so
hier rein wenn ich dann aber im rücken
also das ist eigentlich gar nichts
alle haben ich merke dass nur an der
seite das hat irgendwie mauther
angefangen so ein bisschen zu jung
er wird sich schon jetzt mal ausgezogen
so leute also hier sieht man die naht
und wenn wie hier an liegt die vermutung
nahe dass weil dadurch entsteht
soweit die theorie gerade auch ist weil
ich ja ebenfalls schon im auto saß und
der anschnallgurt die noch daran
gedrückt hat komisch dass sich hier
nicht sagt aber ist halt so entscheidend
bei einer hand einfach mal abwarten und
tee trinken
ich habe mir jetzt gedacht bevor ich
jetzt irgendwie jede stunde update
machen das ist ja langweilig und ich
glaube so schnell passiert er ist auch
nicht mehr so die großen unterschiede
würde ich sagen wir sehen uns einfach
machen heute abend wieder und dann
morgen früh und ich merke wie sich meine
nase irgendwie zu setzen hallo hallo
hallo hallo verbrachten unterschied also
leute erst später und sie jetzt
natürlich dieses wunderschönen t shirt
wieder an
so leute haben jetzt mittlerweile halb
zwölf in fraktion
ich muss ein bisschen länger in der
einzige denn das macht das werden wir
damit mit einer woche sind wir natürlich
ein bonus macht kinder geschlagen sie
hat nur gerade uni freiheits wegen kann
ich mal ein kleines update also ich
hatte wenn ich den ganzen tag das t
shirt an ich hatte eben noch einen pulli
darüber und ich hatte seit ich das
letzte mal weltweit wirklich durch hin
sondern gleich des juden es tut jetzt
nicht werden aber man merkt dass
irgendwas nicht so ganz wichtig ist man
könnte auch sagen dass trend zu leiden
also hier so viel an dieser seite dann
hier und hier an der seite sieht man das
ja auch ex alter gast alter dass er eben
war das noch nicht so schlimm ich habe
auch mal die beiden gruppen da ist
wirklich alles ganz normal die hose
springt zwar extrem aber man merkte gar
nicht die sitzt gut und bequem so als
wenn das ein schlechtes spiel gesehen
dass jeder immer sehen kann auf den
computer auf jeden fall auch und hier
hatte ich auch mal soviel dazu ich würde
sagen damit ich jetzt erstmal schlafen
wahrscheinlich erst stunden oder sogar
ich noch was schneiden was tut ihr das
gefühl ich habe mich irgendwie erhält
wird und es wird schlimmer
aber da werden wir morgen sehen und
jetzt gehts gleich ins bett
wir sehen uns so leute ich geschlafen
wir haben eine nur ungefähr und ich habe
mir eben ernsthaft überlegt ob ich das t
shirt an lassen wird oder nicht weil es
einfach extremst stinkt us- hab ich
ausgezogen aber ich würde sagen wir
schauen einfach mal die das ganze morgen
ist weil wenn ich jetzt schon angefangen
habe dann will ich doch wenigstens ganz
durchziehen und man halt morgen ein
abschließendes fazit zu ziehen aber
eines kann ich jetzt schon sagen die
hose kann man sich auf jeden fall können
verlinkt ich auch gerne in der video
beschreibung das t shirt auf keinen fall
wir sehen uns morgen gute nacht wir
haben jetzt noch mal ein bisschen später
und ich kann nicht schlafen einfach weil
es so dermaßen nach diesem kling stoff
gericht ich hoffe wir sind nicht gerade
überhaupt ich bin mir ganz sicher ich
musste mein bett morgen neu beziehen bin
ich jetzt zum schlafen und ich kann halt
nicht einschlafen bei der nase ist zu
das ist auch noch blöd deswegen schmeißt
sich dieses t shirt jetzt aus meinem
zimmer raus damit sie nicht mehr so
stinkt wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder
ja ja hier versteht dass bis morgen gut
ich glaube die sonne scheint so ich bin
jetzt gerade aufgestanden
[Applaus]
das passt sogar danke januar hier ist
jemand aus dem baum geplumpst so leute
hier mit weil er nicht das video
ich habe das t-shirt heute nacht
aussetzungen es liegt jetzt im müll das
stinkt immer noch brutal die hose war
halt die habe ich gerade auch an habe
ich dich kenne in der video beschreibung
verlinkt das t shirt auf keinen fall
holen
das war das ja fast 24 stunden
experiment ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen ich gerne doch nach oben da und
wir sehen doch die tage wieder ich würde
morgan chase oder instagram ab wir sehen
uns hat ein